now look at Elon Musk how he can play
the media and how he can present it if
this week is about Elon Musk having a
big week for Twitter the platform having
a big week for Elon Musk the power
broker and then having a big week in
general for attention if that's all it
is then that's all it is but if there is
a true friendship in a relationship
forming between DeSantis and musk and
musk can say Ron I've been there this is
how you have to get there I think that's
a very powerful combination if there's a
real relationship there because desantas
can learn from Elon who was very geeky
and and awkward and now can carry his
own with the media